el liderazgo de boris johnson está en
juego después de que el 15% de los
miembros de su partido hayan presentado
cartas pidiendo una moción de censura
tras perder confianza en la capacidad
del primer ministro para hacer su
trabajo la moción de censura obviamente
proporcionará una respuesta clara el
partido tendrá confianza en el liderazgo
o no tendrá confianza en el liderazgo
esa es la cuestión que se planteará hoy
ante mis colegas para que johnson se vea
obligado a abandonar el cargo de primer
ministro al menos la mitad de los
diputados conservadores deben votar en
su contra una vez visto como un líder
carismático que ayudó al partido
conservador a ganar una enorme mayoría
parlamentaria en 2019 el primer ministro
ha estado plagado de una serie de
escándalos desde entonces el más notable
lo que se ha apodado para sí gates una
serie de revelaciones de que downing
street- se saltó las normas de
confinamiento en un momento en el que
las restricciones de la pandemia
impedían al resto del país las
interacciones sociales incluyendo las
visitas a familiares moribundos o para
asistir a funerales en abril más de 100
miembros del gobierno incluido johnson
fueron multados por infligir las vas a
celebrar reuniones de trabajo con
alcohol y hoy he recibido un aviso de
multa fija de la policía metropolitana
relacionado con un evento en downing
street- del 19 de junio de 2020 y
permítanme decir inmediatamente que he
pagado la multa y ofrezco una vez más
una disculpa completa apoye y las
críticas a las acciones de johnson no
han hecho más que crecer desde que se
publicó en mayo un informe de la alta
funcionaria sobre el informe denunció
una cultura en dan street que ignoraba
las advertencias de que esas reuniones
podrían ser ilegales el primer ministro
dijo que asumía toda la responsabilidad
por todo lo que había ocurrido bajo su
vigilancia pero eso no ha servido para
apaciguar al público que abucheó a
johnson durante las celebraciones del
jubileo de la reina este fin de semana
[Aplausos]
atrás las pérdidas electorales en las
elecciones locales de principios de mayo
y la caída de los índices de aprobación
muchos conservadores ven ahora el
liderazgo de johnson como un lastre